今日授業のチャンネルのカバーですね
なんとなんとねこちらに今日はね
あこが
そういやとミクさん家に泊まらせてもらってます今日もよろしくお願いします
早くドイツの編集が持ってくださいへ
2月今日はですね2カメで
サブチャンネルでとミックさんの正体をねそして阿部ということです
かねがね木の実柄やで何度動きをするのかという調査を兼ねてね今日は実際ね
とって動く au 冗談でも一つは金部屋をキレイにするんですけども
今回ん
黒糖かりんとうかりんと思っていうのはね
まあパッドにあっありどうぞ
下咽頭なんですけどパッと見にちょっと
排泄物チップがね排泄物とよねーぞ体質に打つと言わないけどもうちょっとねそれに
近いような感じがあるんで
あの今日今回の動画ですトミックさんの目の前でズボン
パンチからかりんとうを出します
和楽とミクさんが僕をだったりとを出したんですけど
神と辛くと排泄物と勘違いしてしまってどう対応する
僕がその排泄物を出しちゃった仮とだよはいせずはださねぞう解説物をなさないけども
国会に排泄物を出すてこね男の恥ですよすることによって彼はどう反応するかをね
ずっと確かめてみようと思いますではよちょっと水で洗ったり泣かせリアルにか通過し
ました
さ
絶景スタートです
んんん
モーターっていきます入って言うけどね
今日はねとビックチャンスお話でした
保育終わりました
こんなもんすあ
me
高さを受けないですかおっ
かなりたいんですよ
[音楽]
一番する
こっちはとっても食べ過ぎてみたいとらさん
ジャイだっ
甲羅の部分
られています
ちょっと休ませてくださいおっ
苦痛
持っ
[音楽]
うんとウェイ続きます
いいではないんですよね願いします
ん
[音楽]
xeno
花ゆめ本のベル降っ
[音楽]
ええええええ
000にゃん
多分ん
ni
ん
ああああああ
えっ
やばいやばいんじゃなきゃ凄いデハイッ
うっ
[音楽]
うわわふー
3種
グラスちゃいますさ
はぁっ
ああああああ